voilà pour ce plaidoyer ou à dire les
mots comme ils sont en faveur des
prisons ouvertes ça pose évidemment
beaucoup de questions est ce que c'est
possible plus largement qu'on le fait
aujourd'hui en france par exemple est ce
que c'est possible pour tous les détenus
à quelles conditions et puis si la
prison ne punit plus comme dit robert
badinter et on en parlera tout à l'heure
alors à quoi sert-elle on va en parler
justement avec le réalisateur de ce
documentaire bernard nicolas avec nos
invités le sénateur ump jean-rené lecerf
rapporteur du budget de la pénitentiaire
membre de l'observatoire national de la
délinquance
marie créneau qui défend les détenus au
sein de l'observatoire international des
prisons
alexandre jus glaris qui est directeur
général de l'institut pour la justice
qui se fait sur ce plateau mais en
général le porte parole des citoyens et
des victimes et le dernier mais pas le
moindre paul roger gontard
je dis pas le moine parce que vous êtes
l'auteur du rapport qui avait décidé le
gouvernement il ya quatre ans de ça a
lancé la construction de prison sans
murs oui on va voir d'ailleurs où ça en
est on n'est pas très avancé semble-t-il
quatre ans après bernard nicolas d'abord
vous vous intéressez aux prisons depuis
longtemps dans votre esprit il n'y a pas
l'ombre d'un doute quand on voit votre
film n'y a pas l'ombre d'un doute c'est
la solution en tout cas ce qui nous a
intéressés avec un rire lorsqu'on a
commencé à travailler là-dessus commencé
à prospecter à creuser ce sillon là
c'est que on parlait beaucoup et on
parle beaucoup en france de manière
récurrente merci clique de la récidive
et on s'est dit tiens est ce qu'il y a
des moyens de l'éviter de faire baisser
les statistiques en matière de récidive
et est ce que ça se fait dans d'autres
pays que le nôtre puisque le nôtre est
régulièrement condamnée pour l'état de
ses prisons par exemple au niveau
européen on a un regard extrêmement
critique sur la pression française et
donc on s'est dit essayons d'aller voir
si les expériences menées à l'étranger
dans d'autres pays européens
sont exemplaires et vous répondez oui
moi je mangerai s'asseoir je réponds oui
je pense que les statistiques le
démontrent que au delà de l'aspect
purement politique
d'ailleurs un des responsables du
ministère de la justice de
rhénanie-westphalie il explique très
bien il dit on sait très bien que
l'opinion publique n'est pas obligatoire
favorable à ces mesures
mais nous avons fait un choix politique
qui s'appuie sur des statistiques
c'est un regard presque scientifique
qu'ils ont sur la prison ouverte et ils
s'aperçoivent qu'un détenu auquel on va
réapprendre la liberté se débrouille
beaucoup mieux lorsqu'ils la recouvre et
donc c'est un peu dans ce sens qu'on a
essayé de voir si ce postulat
correspondait à une réalité vous dites
oui le journaliste le réalisateur est
conquis le surveillant est conquis le
détenu est content le patron est ravi
c'est un peu tout le monde il est beau
tout le monde il est gentil et votre
film quand même la vie c'est pas
toujours si simple que ça non ya des
rechutes
il ya des gens qui sont difficiles à
récupérer voir qu'on a besoin de sortir
de la société mathieu sont dangereux
bien sûr et c'est nécessaire bien sûr
mais bien sûr je le reconnais et on
explique très bien que tous les détenus
ne sont pas candidats possibles à la
prison ouverte même si il faut qu'ils
soient volontaires ils sont tous
volontaires
simplement ils sont vraiment triés sur
le volet dans tous les pays y compris
pour les expériences embryonnaire en
france comme le centre open aménagé de
metz dans lequel nous avons tourné donc
ça n'est pas ouvert à n'importe qui même
si les allemands on le voit dans le film
je veux dire ça peut pas remplacer la
prison demain au bout du compte quand
vous avez terminé votre documentaire
vous dites pas ça y est c'est ça la
prison de demain non mais c'est une
façon peut-être dans réinsérer beaucoup
plus qu'on ne le fait aujourd'hui de
favoriser leur retour en société vous
avez des chiffres là dessus en tout cas
sur les pays que nous avons visités par
exemple en finlande il est clair que un
quart des détenus récidive
lorsqu'ils sont passés en prison en
prison ouverte les prisons ouvertes
comme à celle de semaine lina par
exemple au large des scènes qui alors
qu'on les finlandais compte à peu près
40% de récidive voire 45 lorsqu'ils
devront / et s'est dit absolument en
tout cas pour la pour la finlande c'est
le cas mais la finlande ce qui est
intéressant
laurent si vous permettez c'est que ils
ont il y à 40 ans complètement changé il
avait proportionnellement à leur
population le taux de récidive le plus
important en europe est le 7ème les durs
et le système le plus dur avec un nombre
de détenus après ce merci voilà par
rapport à la population et il ya 40 ans
ils se sont dit que c'est la question
que vous posiez en préambule
est ce qu'on construit de nouvelles
maisons ou a contrario on change de
système et ils ont changé ils ont décidé
de changer le système d'aller vers ces
prisons où on va favoriser la préparer
le détenu à sa sortie dès le départ et
ils vont en même temps mener une
politique de lutte contre l'échec
scolaire
c'était une réflexion sociétale au sens
large qui a été menée en finlande
c'est en ce sens c'est pour ça qu'on est
allé en finlande parce que ça nous
semblait exemplaire d'une politique
globale qui qui qui a engendré des de
très très bons résultats
je pense que sur une sur 25 ou 30 prison
que compte le pays il y en a aujourd'hui
un quart plus d'une dizaine qui sont des
des prisons ouvertes où on va préparer
un peu comme on le montre le détenu par
le travail en lui accordant de plus en
plus de deux jours de congé
on a des vacances en prison ça peut
surprendre c'est un peu c'est 1.25 à
savoir des jours de vacances alors qu'on
était en prison c'est curieux merci en
tout cas ça lance notre débat et on va
le lancer en retournant en finlande dans
ces prisons ouvertes sont assez
surprenantes bernard nicolas en parlant
de sue ellen l'ina c'est ça c'est le nom
de la prison ouverte disait il ya un
côté auberge de jeunesse et ça ne
déplaît pas amicaux qui est condamné
pour trafic de stupéfiants on n'est pas
dans le monde arabe il ya beaucoup
d'activités que tu peux faire ici on
peut faire du sport
on peut faire des grillades on peut se
baigner que tu fasses tour a toujours
dans notre prison ouverte
on est comme dans un cocon nos
conditions de vie sont excellents
on travaille on rentre du travail on va
directement manger à la cantine on a une
petite pause on reprend le travail
et lorsqu'on rentre le dîner près qu'on
s'occupe d'eux nous presque trop bien et
ça peut même être un peu angoissant de
quitter cette date car tu sais que la
vie gore sera beaucoup plus difficile qu
ici ici c'est l'idéal
ici encore je pouvais y avoir ma femme
et mes chiens je resterai ici toute ma
vie est tellement bien qu'on y
resteraient volontiers même assez
surprenant quand on parle d'une prison
on dit pas ça des prisons françaises
sénateur lecerf est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec l'idée que c'est une des
solutions à envisager pour la france de
manière plus massive
une des solutions oui moi je crois que
le la personne détenue si vous voulez
c'est une étiquette qui recouvre des
réalités extrêmement différentes
la personne détenue s'est pas uniquement
grand banditisme s'est pas uniquement
les grands prédateurs sexuels c'est pas
uniquement des extrémistes terroristes
c'est aussi des voleurs à la tire c'est
aussi des malades mentaux
c'est aussi des gens qui n'ont pas eu de
chance
pourquoi déciderait ton de gérer
l'ensemble de ces personnes de la même
manière par l'enfermement
il y en a pour lesquels l'enfermement
est absolument nécessaire il y en a
d'autres pour lesquels il faut une dose
de liberté qui varient en fonction des
circonstances
vous savez déjà les labellisant à la
carte d'une certaine manière
certainement c'est certainement la
prison la bienvenue pour les plus durs
et la carte pour ce long temps il pense
qu'après tout il ya un chemin est ce ce
qui aspire à redevenir des citoyens
normaux alors la carte ça peut être
d'avoir du travail en prison déjà de
sortir la prison où il ya du travail
c'est déjà une prison qui est à moitié
ouverte
et puis pour un certain nombre de
personnes c'est effectivement la prison
totalement ouverte dont ils ont les clés
de la cellule dans la une en france
d'ailleurs aurait pas parlé il ya casa
miranda mais casabianda en france ce qui
est réservé aux détenus condamnés pour
pédophilie
oui on très largement mais c'est surtout
d'aider des gens moi je les ai
rencontrés à diverses reprises qu'ils
disent
nous n'avons pas besoin de barrow parce
que les barreaux sont dans nos têtes et
ce sont des gens qui à mon avis ne
récidive guerre voire ne récidive jamais
mais vous dites à mon avis on a des
chiffres là dessus renvoyez même bernard
nicolas tout à l'heure mais du mal à
nous donner des chiffres car
malheureusement n'y a pas de chiffres
par sur quoi le la volonté du
législateur n'ait suivi qu'avec beaucoup
de retard dans la loi pénitentiaire
vision claire vous avez demandé
bien sûr dans la loi pénitentiaire avoir
des statistiques des statistiques de
récidive par établissements pour peine
le décret a été pris à la fin de l'année
dernière donc nous aurons peut-être
satisfaction d'ici un an ou deux donc
donc peut-être dans sept ans après que
les législateurs les décider et vous dit
à ma connaissance
à ma connaissance ça marche si on prend
le ski me fait dire ça c'est d'avoir
rencontré effectivement d'avoir discuté
d'avoir parlé très longuement avec les
gens de casabianda vous le savez de 2,2
quand vous avez des gens qui vous disent
nous sommes redevenus des hommes debout
n'ont pas besoin de barreaux les
barreaux sont dans nos têtes
vous vous dites qu'ils ont déjà fait un
chemin important vers la réinsertion à
mauzac dont parlait mais attendez
qu'elle ait un taux de récidive à
casabianda ce que visiblement le
directeur vous l'a dit le taux de
récidive à casabianda selon des
directeurs qui n'ont pas le droit
effectivement un communiqué il est
dérisoire
1 2 3 % je pense je pensais au dortoir
de roller à mouzens bien c'est la
récidive si j'ose dire et artistique
les sortants de prison après cinq ans et
presque 60% sur une clientèle pardonnez
moi de parler comme ça deux condamnés
pour pédophilie
ça dépend entre l'auteur d'infractions
sexuelles intrafamiliales c'est à dire
le pédophile incestueux oui non sous de
10% et le multirécidiviste prédateur
sexuel là on est au lit au delà parfois
des 30% donc c'est ce sont deux publics
il n'est pas à casabianda il n'est pas
dans la prison ouverte française
assurément généralement non c'est là
c'est la pénitentiaire qui choisit
effectivement les personnes qui vont à
casabianda mais si vous prenez l'autre
extrémité pour les délinquants sexuels
c'est quand à quand je suis persuadé que
la récidive elle est au moins
effectivement de moitié et entre deux il
ya cette prison de mauzac qui a été
créée par robert badinter
quand il nous a parlé à 82 où les
résultats sont certainement des
résultats assez intéressant mais moins
qu à casabianda si je peux me permettre
sur les statistiques
l'angleterre a essayé de faire quelque
chose à public comparable on estime que
depuis une prison ouverte on a 3 x men
récidive que depuis une prison ferme est
bon encore une fois vous êtes d'accord
avec cette idée de sélectionner les
détenus marie créneau du point de vue de
l'observatoire international des prisons
oui mais avant en fait fin il faut
rappeler le principe de
l'individualisation des peines
il n'y a pas que la question de savoir
en fait quel type de prison va
construire pour quel type de public et
aussi quel type de sanctions on applique
à des des personnes il ya tout un panel
de sanctions possibles et notamment des
mesures en milieu ouvert de la peine de
probation et qui a des taux de fin les
taux de récidive sont systématiquement
moindres quand on applique ce type
d'investissement m d'envoyer en prison à
la place de la troisième place à la
place de la solution via la proportion
de ces le probation aujourd'hui
des condamnations à la prison juste
d'arriver donc on ne peut pas avoir de
statistiques dernière et après il ya
différentes mesures ya une nouvelle
mesure la contrainte pénale qui a été
créée en de suite ya le sursis avec mise
à l'épreuve qui existe depuis des années
les travaux d'intérêts généraux les
stages de citoyenneté etc
la contrainte pénal a expliqué moi ça ce
com c'est tout neuf on a quand même
certaines mesures de probation c'est à
dire c'est un sujet très polémique
on l'a bien entendu dans le débat
politique mais dans les faits c'est une
mesure de suivi en milieu ouvert avec un
certain nombre en fait de l'interdiction
et obligations qui accompagna la mesure
par exemple une obligation de soins une
obligation de chercher du travail et
tout l intérêt il est surtout en fait
dans la nature de l'accompagnement et la
prise en charge qui est assurée par les
services pénitentiaires d'insertion et
probation des entretiens tout un travail
sur les facteurs de passage à l'acte est
en amont bien évidemment en fait une
évaluation des besoins de la personne
on arrive au même résultat avec le
bracelet électronique à jouer en termes
de baisse du taux de récidive je ne
crois pas le bracelet électronique vous
c'est la question qu'on se pose tous est
de savoir si en gros on a éloigné la
dangerosité d'un individu qui a commis
un délit grave ou un crime le bracelet
électronique c'est un outil le poste
électronique m'empêchera jamais et qui
que ce soit surtout le bracelet fixe tel
qu'il existe en france le pensent les
mobiles en france n'existe qu'à dose
homéopathique
le bracelet fixe est un outil si à côté
de cet outil vous n'avez pas des
personnes pour suivre celui qui
bénéficie de la ménagère est aujourd'hui
elle les conseillers d'insertion et de
probation
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas ils doivent
effectivement faire le tri entre les
personnes qu'ils peuvent suivre parce
que on peut pas suivre 200 personnes en
même temps
cet outil risque de nous amener à des
récidives nombreuses et donc à être
condamné ce qui serait un peu dommage
élections et du gard et ce quelques quel
regard vous portez sur ce débat
finalement assez tolérant
qui avance vers l'idée qu'il faudrait
qu'on fonctionne autrement voilà ce que
j'entends depuis le début de cette
émission
l'idée de fonctionner autrement je crois
qu'elle est assez largement partagé
c'est à dire que ce qui était son
histoire dans les prisons telles
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui ça voulait
dire oui et non c'est à dire on a on a
un effet effectivement de surpopulation
carcérale
à mon avis par un manque de place mais
au delà plus généralement il y a la
question du temps utile du temps de la
détention qu'est ce qu'on fait en prison
et le documentaire laborde assez
largement qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
faciliter la réinsertion
ça c'est à mon avis un angle mort du
débat aujourd'hui parce que on tombe
trop souvent dans des débats assez
manichéen est ce qu'il faut aller dans
l'air tout carcéral le tout réinsertion
et on ne se pose pas les questions
utiles de qu'est-ce qu'on fait du temps
de détention
je pense en particulier au travail et à
la lutte contre la toxicomanie contre
les addictions
mais sur la question des taux de
récidive je pense qu'il faut quand même
préciser à une chose c'est que les
individus qui bénéficient par exemple de
libération conditionnelle d'aménagement
de peine sont ceux qui présentent
auparavant au préalable les capacités de
réinsertion les plus fortes
donc c'est aussi pour ça qu'ils
heureusement qu'il récidive mois il
avait avant de venir que d'une certaine
manière c'est ça vous voulez comprendre
la vraie temps on va dire qu'un détenu
qui participent à un projet de
réinsertion à des probabilités de
récidive qui sont moins importantes que
quelqu'un qui se dégagerait le projet
quelques insertion aujourd'hui en bien
c'est tout le travail des conseillers
d'insertion et de probation qui ne sont
effectivement pas assez nombreux pour
suivre l'ensemble des détenus en france
mais dont il faut simplement faire
attention quand on compare les systèmes
en gardant bien à l'esprit que malgré
tous les individus qui bénéficient
d'aménagements de peine ou de libération
conditionnelle sont ceux qui présentent
le plus de garanties de réinsertion dans
la société et heureusement quelqu'un
vous validez d'une certaine manière les
enquêtes de bernard nicolas en disant ça
quand on amène les gens ramènent les
gens vers le travailler vers la société
en vérité on favorise le retour dans la
salle où il faut mais sans douleur pour
la société qu'il veut car l'as
absolument des dispositifs de suivi
devra insertion je me disais le travail
à mon avis la formation professionnelle
et scolaire parce qu'on sait qu'il ya
des difficultés très importantes parfois
même d'alphabétisation prison mais ça ne
pose ça n'enlève pas la question aussi
des individus dangereux qui ne doivent
pas être traités de la même manière et
c'est tout l'intérêt d'individualiser
les peines mais au delà le suivent
de chaque délinquant parce qu'on peut
avoir même quand on est en milieu ouvert
ou au milieu fermé
une rupture à un moment qui fait qu'on
s'améliore au contraire qu'on peut
aggraver son comportement avec sept
nouveaux lits réagir oui c'est sur cette
question en fait de l'effet de sélection
c'est à dire souvent invalidé en fait
l'idée qu'il ya un moindre récidive dans
le cadre d'aménagement de peine ou de
mesures alternatives en disant que
c'était les candidats qui de toute façon
aller moi avait présenté des garanties
qu'ils allaient faire en sorte qu'ils
allaient moins récidiver ya des études
en fait qu'il neutralise cet effet là
avec un système de groupes témoins et à
caractéristiques sociales ou économiques
égal et le résultat est systématiquement
le même c'est dès lors qu'on privilégie
des mesures en milieu ouvert le taux de
récidive est moindre quelles que soient
les caractéristiques des personnes
telles que soit le détenu d'où qu'il
vienne quelques étés sa vie avant le
taux de récidive est moindre mais
toujours mais après on dans ces cas là
quand ils bénéficient d'aménagements de
perdre on est sur des publics
généralement condamnés à des à des
petites ou moyennes peine on n'est pas
en train de parler des de toute façon du
public qu'on aurait incarcéré pour
lequel on n'aurait pas pensé
immédiatement l'aménagement de peine est
ce qu'il est capable de dire concernant
un braqueur beaucoup dans le reportage
dans le documentaire de bernard nicolas
beaucoup de braqueurs bon est ce qu'on
est capable de dire comment on fait
baisser le taux de récidive chez draka
que dans un cas comme celui là il faut
bien avoir des sas de décompression
on est avec un individu qui dans la
société commune ne respectent pas les
règles qui sont celles de la société
libre qui est donc rentré en prison
parce qu'il a commis un crime et il faut
donc qu au moment où il va au 10 ou 15
un crime ou dix ou quinze ans mais il
est condamné à un temps de panier qu'on
allait être re ont libéré un jour 7e
demain il peut être l'un de nos voisins
et tout l'enjeu c'est d'arriver dans le
cadre de son exécution de peine qu'il
puisse devenir un bon voisin pour chacun
d'entre nous et il se trouve que des
outils comme la prison ouverte qui ne se
substitue pas à ces aménagements pen qui
vient en complément de tout ce qui
existe déjà je crois que c'est un enjeu
qu'il faut mettre aujourd'hui sur la
table
quelle place pour les prisons verte en
france part en europe elles sont
développées ailleurs mais en france on a
plus d'aménagements de peine qu'ailleurs
en france a peut être cet intermédiaire
cet acte préparatoire et pour revenir
sur cette question de la sélection
pour moi c'est un faux débat les
chiffres de la récidive des sortants de
prison ou v
est-ce qu'ils sont si bons parce que les
détenus ont été sélectionnés dans ce
sens les meilleurs ou les chiffres la
récidive de ce qu'ils étaient en vie ou
impression qu'on parle des palmarès des
lycées
donc c'est toujours un peu surprenant
c'est surprenant mais en comprendre les
victimes on compose cibles potentielles
une baisse du taux de récidive
ce sont des victimes en moins bien sûr
ils se sont aussi pour des prisons des
dépenses en moins une prison verte coûte
moins cher rapporte même parfois de
l'argent à la collectivité donc avoir
quelqu'un qui n'aurait pas récidiver à
priori parce que ces facteurs qu'on
l'avait appelée de désiste ans c'est à
dire ce qui lui permet de sortir de son
chemin de criminalité est bien un
individu comme celui ci s'il est dans un
contexte d'exécution de peine qui coûte
moins cher la société qui va avoir une
empreinte carcéral moins violente qui en
plus va l'amener à rembourser ses
parties civiles plus tôt mais c'est tout
au bénéfice de la collectivité avons
plus pour certains délits ou crimes peu
pour d'autres d'abord je voudrais
préciser que lorsque le législateur a
exigé effective bord de connaître le
nombre de récidives par établissements
pour peine c'était pas pour faire le
palmarès des lycées
c'était pour se dire eh bien voilà tel
est l établissement le taux de récidive
n'est pas important donc essayons de
regarder si on ne pourrait pas
généraliser ce qui s'y passe ça témoigne
quand même d'une formidable volonté de
pas citer d'une certaine manière enfin
une vraie absence de transparence
le système pénitentiaire veut pas être
jugé l'administration pénitentiaire a
certainement l'administration la plus
opaque qui existe encore à l'heure
actuelle et il est extrêmement difficile
de la faire bouger elle fait parfois des
belles choses
casabianda c'est bien château thierry
pour les malades mentaux c'est bien mais
elle est incapable de d'investir sur ce
qu'elle a fait de bien
et lorsqu'il ya des dossiers qui sont
des dossiers intéressants comme les
dossiers qui avait développé
effectivement mon collègue jean marie
bockel sur les prisons ouvertes on se
rend compte effectivement quelques
années plus tard rien n'a bougé ou
presque
d'ailleurs on en est où puisque ce
rapport que vous remettez décide jean
marie bockel qui est secrétaire d'état
aux prisons balle dire comme ça au
moment où il parle pas exactement le
l'intitulé c'est le plus intéressant que
ça c'est le premier secrétaire est à la
5ème république sans délégation
ah bon très bien il dit ça va être
formidable
on va en faire plus oui on avait tout
même prêt à moi après ce qu'on a lancé
un projet on avait prévu trois nouveaux
établissements entre 2015 et 2017
et puis le programme immobilier
pénitentiaire a été transformé pour des
contraintes budgétaires
les orientations étaient nouvelles avec
la nouvelle majorité ce qui se
comprennent par ailleurs notamment sur
la vétusté des établissements il a fallu
d'abord rénover les vieux établissements
avant de contre construire de nouvelles
places choix politique mais aujourd'hui
se pose la question effectivement
est ce que notre parc pénitentiaire est
adapté aux peines prononcées dans nos
tribunaux première question et deuxième
question est ce que nous avons
suffisamment de place c'est ce qu'on est
capable d'accueillir dans nos prisons
une de manière disons descente
oui les gens qu'on condamne aller en
prison c'est la question qui
sélectionnera actuellement gouverneur
c'est pour ça qu'il a choisi d'orienter
aujourd'hui son budget pour rénover les
prisons les plus ignobles qui sont
indignes de la république
ce cube au gros du des conditions de vie
des détenus mais on s'occupe pas de leur
réinsertion dans la société ensuite
c'est un peu cette idée là mais il
faudrait déjà pensé que leur contexte
d'incarcération est en soi un facteur de
réinsertion ou au contraire de sérieux
et sur la deuxième partie est donc sur
la deuxième partie je crois qu'on a
déployé depuis des années une extension
du milieu ouvert la peine de probation
est un nouvel exemple plus que dans de
très nombreux pays européens
donc est-ce que face à ce panel d'outils
d'exécution de peine il ya une cohérence
qui a été mise
une histoire pénologie qui a été pensée
je ne crois pas bien au contraire
on est là face finalement un archipel
d'exécution de peine
il faudrait peut-être rentrer dans une
logique qui était celle de la peine
progressive où on disait un individu
vous allez être condamné à une peine
privative de liberté
mais cette privatives privation de
liberté par dont va évoluer dans le
temps les soirs de moins en moins grande
et elle va déboucher vers finalement ce
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui la
libération conditionnelle le bracelet
électronique la semi-liberté mais il
faut que ce soit d'étape en étape et la
prison ouverte a été inventé pour être
une étape de ce parcours là on va y
revenir parce qu'on a l'impression en
france de l'extérieur que les détenus
font jamais la totalité de leur peine ni
même aux disons un peu plus de la moitié
de leur peine les oreilles on va y
revenir parce que c'est une question je
voulais vous poser justement après avoir
vu un nouvel exemple comment choisir
ceux qui peuvent bénéficier alors on va
dire de la prison ouverte puisque
c'était le sujet du documentaire de
bernard nicolas acquis autrement dit
faut-il faire confiance à qui peut-on
faire confiance
redonner une chance d'une certaine
manière c'est le dilemme quotidien de
ceux responsables pénitenciers allemand
celui qui entre dans son bureau est un
jeune homme condamné pour braquage
klaus kleinfeld
enfin on n'a pas affaire à des animaux
quand même dans les candidats c'est à
ces prisons ouvertes
bien sûr ce jeune homme est il dit
lui-même gt1 sauvage assure ce n'est pas
inintéressant d'ailleurs de voir que
l'allemagne qui est un pays qui ne passe
pas pour être d'un laxisme débridée âme
de moins en moins effectivement de deux
personnes détenues et d'autre part
jouent le jeu des prisons ouvertes
alors bien sûr il faut qu'il y ait une
sélection qui s'opère il faut qu'il y
ait une sélection qui s'opèrent sur des
critères qui sont des critères divers la
reconnaît fait la reconnaissance est ce
que ce sont des gens qui reconnaissent
effectivement l'erreur qu'ils ont
commise la volonté de réinsertion les
capacités de l'inter sinda de
réinsertion par la présence de la
famille par la volonté de développer un
travail
et puis je signale que l'on a quand même
en france dès des centres qui sont des
centres extrêmement spécialisé
extrêmement compétents qu'on appelle les
centres nationaux d'évaluation qui
permettent effectivement avec un
parcours de six semaines devant une
équipe devant une équipe
pluridisciplinaire qui va du psychiatre
au personnel pénitentiaire en passant
par le médecin en passant par le
psychologue en passant par les
assistants sociaux qui permet
effectivement de se forger une idée sur
l'individu qui est autrement plus
précise que l'idée que pouvait avoir un
psychiatre au bout d'une demi-heure de
l'examen et si on se trompe
malheureusement tout ce qui est humain
est sujet à l'erreur on se trompe
par exemple aussi on est trompé ce qu'on
peut mais se tromper prenons l'exemple
de la prison ouverte de casabianda pour
les délinquants sexuels
on se trompe on ne l'aurait pas placé à
caen il y aurait eu un nombre de
récidives x 4 donc le seul risque que
l'on prend
c'est le risque de se tromper quatre
fois moi expliquer ça à monsieur juglar
et c'est aux familles des victimes
c'est ça qui est compliqué non je suis à
gérer sur en suisse il suffit dans notre
système médiatique d'avoir un cas de
récidive
spectaculaire et médiatique pour envoyer
au panier si j'ose dire tout ce que vous
venez de dire pardon de le dire aussi
les bourdes album et c'est ce qui se
passe non c'est ce qui se passe aussi et
pardonnez moi mais quand on utilise à
mon avis à tort l'expression prison
ouverte parce que pour l'opinion
publique la prison sont des murs et
c'est un moment où l'individu est placé
à l'écart de la prison je pense que les
centre pour peines aménagées un centre
de réinsertion par le travail sont des
termes qui sont plus adaptées parce que
si on veut faire admettre à l'opinion
publique un certain nombre d'évolutions
il ne faut pas utiliser des mots qui
sont compris différemment dans l'opinion
publique et dans le cas que vous évoquez
c'est à dire quand il ya une récidive
terrible malheureusement assez souvent
quand même il ya eu défaillance de
l'administration pénitentiaire par
exemple dans le suivi personnes qui
récidivent où l'on parlait de la
réduction des peines il existe
aujourd'hui en france on a fait le choix
de réduire les peines parce qu'on a
effectivement ce phénomène de
surpopulation carcérale
alors on individualise pas on ne fait
pas passer par une sorte de sas comme
vous disiez une prison qui serait plus
tourné vers la société qui faciliterait
la réinsertion
non on a fait le choix de réduire les
peines pour faire sortir plus tôt et en
général les cas les plus symboliques ce
qui émeut justement l'opinion sont ceux
dans lesquels on a fait sortir un
individu plutôt pour lequel le suivi a
été défaillant et qui est à nouveau
passé à la descente mais plutôt parce
que bonne conduite parce que tu romandie
la guerre la cumuler les points qui lui
permettent de sortir pas cela soit
clarika sur le système en disant ça pas
seulement parce que par exemple vous
avez ce qui s'appelle les crédits de
réduction de peine automatiques qui sont
contraires absolument à l'idée
d'individualisation c'est à dire
automatiquement réduit de quelques mois
la détention chaque année ces crédits de
réduction de peine automatiques ne sont
quasiment jamais supprimé pour tous les
individus qui passent par la case prison
l'expression vous répondais mais en voir
débattre parce que je vois que je suis
j'ai suivi un désaccord mais vous
répondre à une question je me suis posé
en regardant le documentaire je voyais
ce détenu allemand où le riche de croix
qui a été condamné pour braquage
condamné à 10 ans de prison il passe six
ans en prison ferme et donc en prison si
vous voulez au terme selon les termes
comme on les comprend où comme vous
voulez qu'on les comprenne et puis là il
paye pas son milieu en prison ouverte il
bon pour une durée si j'ai bien compris
de deux ans il serait sorti au bout de
combien de temps en france ulric en
france au bout de six ans est ce qu'il
n'est pas dehors
il peut être dehors il peut être dehors
mais marc besoin de passer par la case
prison verte
il peut être dehors mais il il aurait
était dehors avec des aménagements de
peine c'est à dire en semi-liberté en
placement à l'extérieur progressif
peut-être avec des contraintes
particulières qui accompagnerait cette
libération sans aucun doute faut pas
penser non plus que en france lorsqu il
y à un aménagement de peine
on vous ouvre la porte merci monsieur
d'avoir passé ces quelques années dans
la prison et au revoir
on se revoit peut-être demain c'est pas
du tout ça au contraire on est dans un
cycle malgré tout bien que par manque de
moyens ou on a des professionnels qui
essaie d'accompagner ces libérations si
vous l'avez liger c'est à dire sans
parler de déficit de personnel d'où
l'enjeu d'avoir ce qu'il dit très bien
il dit dans cet établissement je sais ce
que j'ai à perdre ce genre de prison
ouverte et peut-être les aménagements de
peine d'une certaine manière créer une
forme d'épée de damoclès au-dessus de
sus de la tête des condamnés qui recrée
finalement ce poids qui est celui de la
société commune où la sanction vient
après l'infraction après le crime
en prison on fait tout pour empêcher
qu'il se passe quelque chose de
dramatique on érige pas parce que la
violence en prison elle est réelle le
trafic de drogue il est réel mais
néanmoins on met des murs pour empêcher
des évasions par exemple pendant les
socialistes aussi était autrement mais
dans la société on n'a pas un policier
derrière chacun d'entre nous pour nous
empêcher de commettre un crime et donc
d'avoir ce processus là de
réappropriation de la responsabilité
individuelle c'est fondamental et les
prisons ouvertes peuvent tea party mais
je retiens quand même ce que vous m'avez
dit en répondant à ma première question
c'est à dire qu'effectivement ulrich
serait sorti de prison en france ce sans
avoir bénéficié d'un travail de ré
stress à peine d'une manière dijon ces
modalités d'exécution de la peine il est
toujours en train d'exécuter sa peine
quand il est en aménagement de peine il
serait par exemple placer dans un centre
de placement à l'extérieur qui ressemble
peu ou prou finalement à une prison
ouverte c'est simplement que c'est pas
géré par l'administration pénitentiaire
ça peut être des structures associatives
avec une mise au travail salarié tout un
accompagnement et une forme de contrôle
par le parlaient les services
pénitentiaires d'insertion et de
probation et il exécute sa peine il ya
une vraie erreur a considéré que dès que
la personne et n'est plus en prison
il comprenait que le doj du code pénal
c'est à dire que le juge prononce eu ça
le juge devant les justiciables prononce
une peine d'emprisonnement moi ce que
j'entends les gens c'est qu'ils me
disent sans arrêt mais toute façon on
sait très bien qu'on fait jamais
s'appelle dans ce pays des choses aux
doutes ont fait s'appelle oui on
l'exécuté comprise ont d'autre part se
trouve en prison et pour une part
ensuite de manière encadrée dans la dans
la dans la société et c'est d'ailleurs
un des meilleurs moyens de prévenir la
récidive justement parce que ça permet
ce sas parce que ça permet d'acquérir
une se responsabiliser s'autonomiser
après il ya le problème c'est qu'on n'a
pas de prisons ouvertes mais on a du
milieu ouvert on a dû medio problème
c'est qu'il faut réfléchir aussi au
temps passé en détention avant pour
qu'il soit le moins destructeur possible
qu'il abîme le moins possible les
personnes le problème des réductions de
peine se compliquent encore par le fait
que les cours d'assises notamment très
souvent anticipent la réduction de peine
moi j'ai un président de cour d'assises
qui me donner un exemple c'était une
personne qui était poursuivi pour en
tant que délinquant sexuel
intrafamiliales et le jury avait décidé
que cette personne ne sortirait que
lorsque sa fille cadette serait majeure
elle avait 11 ans donc le jury avait
décidé qu'on mettait sept ans et le
président de la cour d'assises a dit non
parce que les réductions de peine il est
sorti avec 14 ans et donc il a fait sept
ans ce qui est ou le prendre un teg la
réduction de peine il dans la peine dans
les yeux
jury d'assises très souvent intègre la
réduction de peine dans la durée de
peine qu'il a souhaité orissa bien sûr
si existant mais c'est une façon
effectivement de faire en sorte que la
volonté du jury populaire sont
respectées mais c'est ce qui choque
paradoxalement ou et à raison à mon avis
l'opinion publique qui entend une peine
prononcée
c'est à dire quinze vingt ans de prison
et qui apprend souvent malheureusement
alice et d'une récidive que la personne
n'a pas fait cette détention
c'est pour ça que la question des
crédits de réduction de peine pause pose
question parce qu'elles dénaturent le
sens de la peine et notamment d'un sens
de la peine qui est prononcée devant
l'opinion publique les lieux condamnés à
des peines fermes or points non non je
n'aurais imaginé tendant vers vous je
vais chercher un nom faut déjà réfléchir
à mr type de sanction possible et dans
bien des cas ça n'est absolument pas la
prison ensuite le problème des
réductions de peine c'est vrai qu'il
peut y avoir un problème de lisibilité
si l'europe
si c'est si c'est pas expliqué mais
ensuite on a des retraits si ça a été
créée aussi c'était pour s'assurer
d'avoir un moyen de contrôler aussi le
comportement des personnes en détention
c'est à dire d'avoir un bâton si jamais
se comporte mal on leur retire des
crédits de réduction de peine et ça
existe et ça existe très souvent ça
fonctionne et c'est utile est la
question est ce que ça fonctionne et
c'est utile parce que là on est dans un
cadre si utilisé comme un outil de
gestion de la détention il pourrait y
avoir aussi des grandes enchères des
taux d'occupation au lieu de gérer des
individus ce qui pourrait y avoir cédé
peines prononcées moins longues et à un
système aussi qui a intégré à la pelle
qu'une partie de la peine s'exécute si
automatiquement systématiquement sauf
sauf opposition d'un magistrat et finit
en aménagement de parler de lui
autrement dit est-ce qu'on a les moyens
pardonnez moi que c'est une question
précise est-ce qu'on a les moyens de
contrôler hors les murs lorsque là
aujourd'hui et s qui a suffisamment
d'aujourd'hui la fonctionnaire
d'éducateurs poursuivre la réponse mais
il ya un personnage
il va aujourd'hui vous avez aujourd'hui
de constater aujourd'hui effectivement
le rôle je laisse de côté les
associations et spécialisés le rôle des
conseillers d'insertion et de probation
il ya des efforts qui sont faits pour
augmenter le nombre des conseillers
d'insertion et probation monsieur
ayrault par exemple notre ancien premier
ministre avait annoncé je pense que ce
sera ça sera
suivi mise en bouche sur trois ans ce
qui était déjà promis d'ailleurs en 2009
à l'époque de la loi pénitentiaire qui
n'avait pas été fait mais même s'ils ont
les fesses et ses embauches un
conseiller d'insertion et de probation
va devoir suivre entre 100 et 120
dossiers ce qui n'est pas raisonnable
donc il faudrait effectivement qu'il y
en ait davantage mais s'il y al'avantage
de conseillers d'insertion et probation
on ne construira pas de nouvelles
prisons parce qu'on n'aura pas les
moyens de le faire donc nous sommes
devant une situation que tu une
situation qui est gérée par les
problèmes financiers
soit on construit de nous des prisons
nouvelles et à ce moment là faut
embaucher des personnels de surveillance
et on n'a pas les moyens d'embaucher des
personnels d'insertion et de probation
soit on fait d'un verre semé faire les
deux donc je dois en faire un choix et
la trêve est en train dé la prison peut
être la réponse de ce choix la prison il
peut le devenir pour la bonne et simple
raison que un établissement fermé un
mirador ses sept équivalents temps plein
pour le faire fonctionner cette poste
dans une prison ouverte vous n'avez pas
de miradors donc si personnelle là vous
les remettez dans la détention il
accompagne le détenu donc cet
établissement coûte moins cher comme je
disais tout à l'heure mais aussi permet
d'avoir un contact humain plus régulier
plus proche plus efficace et finalement
je voudrais pas que autres cet avion se
méprenne une prison vers c'est une
prison c'est un lieu d'exécution de
peine signalé circonstancié dans lequel
le détenu doit rester comme ça qui a
parfois peut-être une confusion y
compris dans dans le reportage un centre
pour peines aménagées n'est pas une
prison ouverte la particularité d'une
prison ouverte c'est que un centre pour
peines aménagées sais quoi parce qu'il
ya cinq ans france c'est à dire que
c'est un lieu d'exécution de peine ou le
condamné va exécuter une partie de sa
peine au dehors dans ce qu'on va appeler
le milieu ouvert dans la société dans le
travail et autres soeurs travailler dans
les prisons ouvertes le plupart du temps
les détenus restent sur le périmètre de
l'établissement
sauf qu'ils aient pas mûre pour les
contraindre ya rien pour les empêcher de
finalement s'évader puisque c'est bien
de ça dont on parle dans le cas d'une
paire d'écouteurs d'évasion si j'ai bien
compris
benthiff conventionnelle autre nom qui
est proportionnelle à l' usage des
prisons ouvertes ans au danemark là vous
avez presque un tiers des établissements
ouverts vous avez un taux élevé
d'évasion lorsque vous adresser à un
public jeune par exemple ya un gros
risque d'évasion par contre lorsque vous
sélectionnez efficacement et détenus
lorsque vous avez un contrôle précis des
arrivants vous avez des taux dérisoires
d'évasion voir aucune comme à casabianda
c'est une île sinon il n'ya pas
d'évasion oui en suisse est quand même
peu d'il ya très peu d'évasion de toutes
les prisons ouvertes et ce que disait le
responsable de la prise de vue
directement dans le documentaire
il ya quand même chose autour de
laquelle on tourne à travers les
questions je vous pose depuis le début
de ce débat c'est que la société accepte
mal l'idée qu'on aide les détenus d'une
manière générale qu'on s'occupe des
détenus avant de s'occuper des victimes
parfois que c'est la télévision cellule
qu'on leur facilite la vie d'une
certaine manière c'est ce que robert
badinter appelle la loi d'airain
vous ne pouvez pas dans une société
démocratique élevé ou améliorer la
condition des détenus et la rendre
meilleure que la condition du
travailleur libre le plus défavorisés
parce que la société ne l'admet pas que
ses hommes ont failli et ils ont violé
la loi
ils ont tenté à froid ou communément à
d'autres ils peuvent être punis c'est le
mot de code pénal est très révélateur il
s'agit de punir et qu'est ce que la
punition la peine veut dire la douleur
et au fond de l'inconscient collectif et
à cette idée qu'ils doivent payer
alexandre glaris il faut payer sa dette
à la société
ou pas c'est le principe de la sanction
quand on à transgresser la règle commune
la loi définit par le législateur il
faut être sanctionnés parce que sinon il
n'y a plus de vie ensemble n'ya plus de
règles communes
si chacun est libre de ne pas respecter
la loi ne pas respecter la lettre la
règle commune sans sanctions il ya plus
de vie en société possible donc il faut
que ce soit une douleur bon ne serait ce
que par la privation soient culturels
aujourd'hui ce à quoi la religion la
peine absolument le principe de
l'affliction c'est très attachés à notre
conception de la prison qui est très
monastique
on vient de la une près c'est une
perception judéo catholique ou pour
retrouver finalement le pardon le salut
faut payer par la souffrance mais elle
est dans les pays de tradition plutôt
luthérienne calviniste là le salut
a absolument rien avec votre souffrance
il est soit de prêts destinés par dieu à
vous arrivez sur terre pendant de faire
un peu de gym et notre récent parce
qu'il sait que la brise island en suisse
et en allemagne sont en angleterre dans
des pays dont on arrive à avancer sur
ces sujets et de grèves dans dans ces
pays là la question de la rédemption le
retour à la société passe plutôt par
quelles fonctions vous occuper dans le
groupe parce que vous êtes utile au
groupe
plutôt que de savoir si vous allez payer
non il faut que vous resterez billet ce
que vous avez fait mais non pas le payer
par votre souffrance c'est très
important et je revienne tout à l'heure
sur la loi d'airain parce que le
luxembourg a trouvé une solution pour sa
dont la loi pénitentiaire le législateur
a voulu inscrire le sens de la peine
alors je dis pas comme il s'est pas
trompé mais il a essayé de définir le
sens de la peine comme étant d'abord la
sanction parce que je crois
qu'effectivement il y à une sanction qui
doit effectivement appliqué mais dire
cela c'est la peine c'est aussi la façon
de prendre en compte la douleur des
victimes et d'indemniser les victimes
et enfin la peine c'est aussi le travail
de réinsertion pour que la personne
puisse ensuite mené 10 le législateur
une vie normale et exemple d'un chat
c'est écrit dans la loi c'était minable
c'est écrit dans la nouvelle loi quand
même la loi prévoit la peine pas la
prison j'ai ce que veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui la peine c'est un temps
prison qui est conçu dans l'inconscient
collectif comme la sécurité ou comme
pour certains personnels ministration
pénitentiaires pour la sécurité et la
réinsertion ce sera le milieu ouvert
c'est c'est finalement la
réinterprétation de ce qu'avait dit le
président giscard d'estaing alors qu'il
avait dit la prison c'est la privation
de liberté n'est rien d'autre eh bien là
n'étaient pas conçues comme je suis en
train de vous l'exprimer mais depuis 75
ans n'est pas loin de ça il ya un faux
débat dans lequel on s'empêtre depuis
des décennies c'est à faut-il d'abord
lutter contre la récidive
au fond ou faut-il d'abord faciliter la
réinsertion la meilleure façon de lutter
contre la récidive cette faciliter la
réinsertion
donc c'est l'avers et le revers à rome
est donné dans les tenues on protège ses
pas on est donc c'est en lui imposant
les moyens de ne pas ré insérer je pense
par exemple serait de ne pas récidiver
l'exemple à mon avis le plus important
c'est la lutte contre les addictions
parce qu'on sait que c'est un facteur
majeur de passage à l'acte et de
récidive potentiel tant qu'on n'aura pas
ni des moyens suffisants pour lutter
contre toutes les addictions d'ailleurs
toxiques et autres on n'aura pas les
moyens durablement de faire diminuer la
récidive et ça c'est un je le redis mais
c'est un angle mort aujourd'hui dans la
réflexion de l'administration
pénitentiaire par dans une question
idiote les toxicomanes sont aidés en
prison ou au contraire et bénéficie d'un
finalement de de fourniture de drogue
comme on peut en trouver dehors tout se
passe c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent
et il ya des unités sanitaires ils
peuvent si c'est une dépendance aux
opiacés avoir des traitements de
substitution qui peuvent c'est à dire
s'ils le veulent
oui il n'ya pas de on n'est pas dans un
système en train d'installer un système
de soins contre 1 peut y avoir en fait
par derrière de fortes incitations à ce
que vous dites tous que c'est un une
cause de récidive importante
oui mais une des conditions aussi pour
que ça marche et qu'il ya une alliance
thérapeutique est donc une adhésion et
donc pas bah ils peuvent être incités
pas contrainte de toute façon
d'administrer pas des traitements de
sans le consentement de des personnes le
problème c'est qu'on a aussi du coup en
prison des médecins parce qu'il ya du
trafic qui se mettent par exemple à
délivrer des traitements substitution de
manière diluée ou piles et pour éviter
en fait que la personne veut garder
ensuite trafic
sauf que dans ces cas-là ça à sa nuit au
principe actif ça ne fonctionne plus
donc on est dans un système où à la fois
il ya du soin même temps il ya du trafic
où il ya du trafic pourquoi parce qu'il
ya aussi de la misère en détention et on
est aussi dans des conditions de
détention qu'ils sont pas forcément très
favorable au fait de quitter les
logiques addictives donc il faut
réfléchir beaucoup plus globalement et
encore une fois je pense qu'au milieu
ouvert pour une bonne part des pour tous
ceux qui ont commis des petits délits en
fait le traitement des addictions et
serait beaucoup plus simple qu'en
détention qui remit lieu pathogène en
soit vous dites tous ce soir sur ce
plateau cogner plus ça sert à rien bien
sûr il ya une étude 66 d'un américain
qui s'appelle gibbs la certitude de la
sanction est deux fois plus dissuasif
que la sévérité de la peine je lançais
mathématiques et pour revenir sur ce
sujet des addictions la prison ouverte
peut devenir finalement un échange un
deal un contrat entre le condamné est
celui qui étant incarcéré en disant si
vous voulez vous profiter d'un espace où
vous avez plus de liberté il faut
accepter certaines contraintes dont par
exemple aller vers le soin et c'est le
cas par exemple du luxembourg qui a une
unité de traitement et d'accompagnement
dans la seule prison vers qu'ils ont il
ya deux prisons au luxembourg et fermer
l'une ouverte et il nous met beaucoup de
moyens vers la réinsertion
c'est à dire vers l'accompagnement par
le travail par les soins et on peut se
dire que c'est choquant parce que ces
gens là ont commis un crime ce que
disait robert badinter c'est la loi
d'airain et bien eux sont allés très
loin
il autorise les volontaires dans cette
prison ouverte depuis qu'elle a été
créée c'est à dire plus d'un siècle
il ya ce statut qui permet à quiconque
qui voudraient bénéficier de tout cet
ensemble d'accompagnement re socialisant
et de services d'accompagnement et bien
finalement chaque année il y en a pas ou
très peu et se sont le plus souvent des
détenus de l'établissement qui n'ont pas
encore trouvé de lieu où aller ce qui
signifie que la liberté est beaucoup
plus cher pour un individu que tous ces
services d'accompagnement et de services
sociaux que l'on peut trouver dans une
prison comme givenich alexandre c'est
pourquoi on avait choisi la privation de
liberté comme peine
bien sûr nous ne versons pas non plus
dans l'angélisme je reviens à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure en disant que
dans la prison il ya des personnalités
extrêmement différentes il ya d'abord
des malades mentaux qu'il faudrait faire
sortir de la prison des malades très
lourd qui ne savent même pas
effectivement ce qu'il faut en prison et
pourquoi ils sont là et puis il y as je
crois une part très faible mais une part
malgré tout qu'on ne peut pas
sous-estimer de personnes qui ne sont
pas rien c'est râble pour lesquels
effectivement la prison sera
vraisemblablement le dernier itinéraire
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a créé
il ya pas si longtemps la rétention de
sûreté
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat vous pourrez
continuer à déposer évidemment vos
questions vos réactions sur la boîte
mail de l'émission et la semaine
prochaine on parlera dans le docu débat
du marché des matières premières a très
vite
en tout
en fout
coc